à l'opposé du spectre des trafiquants de
drogue les agences de sécurité privée
doivent incarner la loi et l'ordre sauf
que dans le cas de l'agence Neptune on
est complètement sur une autre planète
plus tard à l'émission notre équipe des
masques le patron d'une grande
entreprise de sécurité privée qui a
obtenu des centaines de millions de
dollars du gouvernement notamment pour
surveiller des postes de police et des
palettes de justice
je serai étonné de voir la réaction des
juges c'est une fraude ici Marie Moore
Denis bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
il y a un peu plus d'une semaine
l'Agence des services frontaliers du
Canada à l'arguine Neptune une agence de
sécurité privée justement en invoquant
des problèmes de sécurité mais ce que
notre équipe a découvert sur le patron
de cette entreprise et tout simplement
incroyable
[Musique]
a toujours bénéficié d'un service de
sécurité privée qui venait un peu en
renforcement au niveau de service
politique qui était déjà à
[Musique]
verduniste le cavagorié le contrat comme
plus beau semi
c'est qui les dirigeants de Neptune
c'est pas loin d'être clair parce que là
on s'est aperçu que la compagnie avec
différentes ramifications on a eu
l'information comme quoi il y avait des
choses douteuses qui se passaient puis
il y a des feuilles de temps qui sont
remplies de façon illégale je dis ok de
sens alors pour nous c'était le cet
éclat une fois la faire quelque chose
[Musique]
la sécurité privée visible partout au
Canada et au Québec une industrie
sensible et réglementée qui emploie des
dizaines de milliers de personnes la
sécurité privée fait partie du grand
domaine de la sécurité il faut le voir
comme étant un continent dans le cadre
des agents de sécurité dans le secteur
du gardiennage ça vise en seulement à
prévenir le crime des choses comme ça
si moindrement ça chauffe on leur dit
d'appeler le milieu policier dans cette
industrie un joueur se démarque Neptune
service de sécurité cette agence a connu
une forte croissance ces dernières
années en décrochant des centaines de
contrats publics un peu partout au pays
uniquement au Québec la valeur des
contrats dépasse les 200 millions de
dollars alors Neptune intervient à
Verdun lors de l'appel d'oeuf en 2014
dans les contrats d'appel d'offres
publics il y a des règles à respecter le
plus beau semestre gagne de facto
l'appel d'offres il doit être aussi
conforme je connaissais pas du tout la
compagnie Neptune mais il est peut-être
plus beau
dans le fond au niveau de l'appel
d'offres alors on a donné le contrôle
[Musique]
je voulais savoir tout tout parce que je
la crois que ça arrive justement
on avait des petites rumeurs qui
circulaient comme quoi que le nombre de
poses était douteux pas longtemps après
un hasard une longue personne vient me
voir le me dit est un problème avec la
compagnie de sécurité parce que il y a
une personne d'entreprise qui signe des
feuilles de temps il donne plus d'heures
que prévu j'avais vu des vidéos sur les
réseaux sociaux de gens qui perdaient
leur temps de certains endroits les gens
n'aiment taguer Monsieur le Maire penser
de ça c'est sûr c'est inacceptable
[Musique]
à ce moment-là je me suis viré vers le
contrôlage général de la ville comme on
devrait toujours faire et en expliquant
la situation j'ai demandé une enquête
interne
à ce moment-là c'est simple ils ont
installé des GPS en dessous des voitures
des patrouilleurs alors que personne
savait que s'est installé les véhicules
se promenaient et on pouvait dans le
fond enregistrer tous les déplacements
alors on a vu que les arts qui nous
étaient facturés pendant la même période
correspondait pas nécessairement au
déplacements qu'on avait sur le GPS je
me souviens c'était autour de 800 heures
de se facturation pour la période de
l'enquête c'était énorme au départ
l'intégrité
c'est une notion qui est partout dans le
droit quand on a la preuve qui a des
manoeuvres dolosives ou que une
entreprise fait des fausses
représentations ça a toujours été un
motif pour par exemple résilier un
contrat on va faire des vérifications
d'antécédents on va regarder les mœurs
des gens qui qui jouent des rôles
centrales dans l'entreprise c'est un
privilège que toi d'avoir un permis
spoil doit absolu nous avons décidé de
faire nos propres vérifications sur
l'agence de sécurité Neptune j'en ai
appris un peu plus sur l'entreprise qui
était une entreprise ontarienne
dans les documents officiels de Neptune
nous retrouvons une adresse à
Mississauga
non vos siège social de la compagnie
Neptune on va voir de quoi ça a l'air
c'est une certaine hammam ou Tahir qui
serait la propriétaire de la compagnie
trouver les bureaux de Neptune n'est pas
si simple
on se retrouve dans un centre commercial
qui semble des affecter
on arrive ici près d'un Dollarama et
d'un père Noël géant il n'y a pas de
bureau on est à la bonne adresse donc
c'est bien le siège social de Neptune
normalement il y a un bureau c'est le
bureau 539 mais il y a juste des boîtes
postales et il y a une boîte postale 539
donc le siège social c'est la voie
postale
[Musique]
chez Neptune des chèques qui
rebondissent
c'est monnaie
Neptune il y a eu un entente alors la
copie m'a envoyé un chèque à partir d'un
compte qui était fermé alors moi
j'aurais dit non non ça marche pas comme
ça ce chèque s'approvision est un chèque
de trop pour Monsieur Jenkins les deux
parties n'arrivent plus à s'entendre
j'étais chez moi en train de rédiger sur
mon ordinateur
oui je vous connais pas vous êtes qui
vous je suis le propriétaire de Neptune
y était une série vous avez payé des
gamins il m'a dit
j'appelle de Toronto il s'est même
effectivement au téléphone mais dans un
excellent français dès que ça a pris des
proportions de propos si gratuits je lui
raccroche au nez ah il m'avait dit à
l'époque qui prendrait toutes les
ressources financières de son entreprise
pour me laver financièrement
ça pourrait durer 10 ans si vous voulez
alors vous comprenez que
j'appelle de toute façon de
l'intimidation monsieur Jenkins poursuit
actuellement Robert bottler et Neptune
la compagnie soutient d'avoir rien à se
reprocher et dans sa défense il dit que
l'agent de sécurité n'a jamais travaillé
pour elle c'est ça qui me fait m'avait
surpris parce que je l'ai travaillé
qu'avec un uniforme de Neptune et là que
je considère pas la bonne compagnie
allô
[Musique]
nous apprenons Robert Baudelaire à
témoigner à plusieurs reprises en cours
à titre de PDG de Neptune
idée
j'ai aucune idée d'identité du monsieur
parce qu'en allant vérifie n'importe qui
peut le faire d'ailleurs sur les sites
d'information d'entreprise
gouvernementale son nom ne figure nulle
part
mais qui est ce Robert Butler après la
pause visite en caméra cachée
[Musique]
on prétend que les agences de sécurité
privée sont scrutés à la loupe qu'il y a
tellement de contrôles le Bureau de la
sécurité privée la SQ l'UPAC le
gouvernement fédéral mais Neptune les a
tous rouler dans la farine
[Musique]
nous poursuivons nos recherches pour
découvrir qui se cache vraiment derrière
l'agence de sécurité Neptune l'ancien
maire de Verdun nous apprend qu'il y a
un prix à payer pour s'opposer à cette
compagnie
du rapport du contrôlage général j'ai
rencontré mes élus pour résilier contrat
je mettais pas de Gamblin des fois quand
j'étais fâché ou plus émotif quand
j'engage une femme de ménage chez nous
ou un homme de ménage qui vient voler
puis je dis je voulais juste te rappeler
dans ton cadre de l'emploi tu ne dois
pas voler quand tu es rendu là ça va pas
bien je vous ai traité de voleur et ça
va pas plus du tout à l'entreprise
Neptune alors suite à la fin du contrat
tout de suite ils ont entamé une
poursuite et on profitait de l'occasion
dans le fond pour me poursuivre aussi
pour diffamation ça ça se rapproche
beaucoup de de des espèces de poursuites
Bayon c'est même aujourd'hui je fais
d'entrevue là je me dis qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont tomber sa tête après passe une
entreprise qui est tendance à faire ça
Robert Butler a témoigné pour Neptune
lors de la poursuite contre le maire
Parenteau qui est Robert Baudelaire
Robert botelard j'attendais son nom
circulait
le patron Neptune n'apparaît pourtant
nulle part dans les documents officiels
ni sur le site de la compagnie mais on
retrouve son nom ailleurs sur le web je
suis maintenant sur un blog de compagnie
de transport ça remonte à une dizaine
d'années peut-être on voit qu'il y a des
propriétaires de compagnies de transport
qui parlent de Robert botler et aussi
badream à madoune
[Musique]
avez-vous déjà entendu parler d'une
personne qui s'appelle Badreddine
amadoune
Badreddine
je me souviens pas du tout
badridine Amadou n'est un homme
d'affaires de la région de Toronto
en 2008 il annonçait vouloir investir
des millions de dollars en Amérique
latine cet homme pourrait avoir été un
proche associé de Robert Butler
nous décidons de le contacter sans dire
que nous sommes journalistes badridine
Amadou n'est responsable de l'agence
immobilière Lemax à missoga la même
ville où se trouve le siège social de
Neptune nous nous faisons passer pour
des clients à la recherche d'une maison
il rappelle un membre de notre équipe
nous nous rendons au rendez-vous muni
d'une caméra cachée
[Musique]
un logo de Neptune la compagnie de
sécurité de Robert Butler
[Musique]
bonjour oui ça va bien
amadoune
alors ça vous êtes dans le bon moment
d'acheter
ne serait pas seulement actif en
immobilier
en plus on est des développeurs
n'explique pas qui sont ces milliers
d'employés au Québec et il n'est ni
question de Neptune ni de Robert
Baudelaire
ça c'est une le site de l'entreprise
Neptune aujourd'hui donc j'ai juste
imprimé une de leurs pages jamais
Neptune n'a perdu de clients en raison
d'un manquement à ses obligations
[Rires]
c'est faux dans le sens que nous déjà on
partait à l'arrondissement de Verdun on
a mis fin au contrat puis c'est pas le
seul c'est Montréal aussi c'est odieux
nous demandons un collaborateur de
contacter la compagnie Neptune et de
prendre rendez-vous avec Robert botler
en se faisant passer pour un potentiel
client ça fonctionne
ce sont les mêmes bureaux que ceux de la
compagnie immobilière Lemax de batterie
Dean
mais vous êtes francophone c'est rare de
rencontrer
Robert botler badridienne amadoune c'est
la même personne d'avoir une double
identité c'est évidemment passer d'une
condamnation criminelle ce qui se
représente sous deux identités
différentes cette personne-là est le de
la loi dans le cours de ces affaires si
quelqu'un était moins d'une situation un
employé d'agence fonctionnerait avec
deux identités et qu'évidemment nous
aurait pas donné la bonne identité
a priori un problème avec ça là
récemment neptune a décroché des
contrats avec de grandes institutions
dont la Sûreté du Québec et la GRC et
ici pour surveiller des migrants des
tensions un contrat que l'agence a perdu
pour avoir mis en péril la sécurité des
détenus Neptune fait aussi le
gardiennage de nombreux palais de
justice au Québec
la réaction des juges
Robert bottler dit à notre collaborateur
avoir des contrats avec la défense
nationale et des autorisations pour
accéder à des informations top secrètes
pour comprendre pourquoi Robert Butler
utilise deux identités pour diriger ses
entreprises nous l'appelons
oui bonjour j'aimerais parler avec
Monsieur Robert Butler s'il vous plaît
oui bonjour je m'appelle Gaëtan Pouliot
je suis journaliste à l'émission Enquête
de Radio-Canada ben on aimerait savoir
notamment c'est qui Badredine amadoune
OK
ok
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que Robert
bottler si votre vrai nom
avec laquelle que je travaille c'est
réservateur je l'avais changé j'ai des
documents qui étaient changés comme ça
donc vous étiez monsieur badritine
Amazon et vous avez changé de nom pour
Monsieur Robert Bachelard exactement
est-ce que vous pouvez me prouver que
vous avez changé de nom pour Robert
bateleur et que si c'est votre offre
celle
j'ai besoin de savoir pourquoi vous
utilisez deux noms et c'est lequel votre
vrai nom c'est Monsieur badredinamadoun
ou c'est Monsieur Robert bottler votre
prénom
c'est lui qui agit pour l'entreprise il
ne peut pas en même temps être une autre
personne dans le cadre de d'autres
fonctions au téléphone Robert Baudelaire
y va d'une autre déclaration étonnante
comme vous dirigez la compagnie
selon nos informations Robert bottler
est pourtant encore aujourd'hui le grand
patron de Neptune nous apprenons qu'il a
fait l'objet de plusieurs poursuites
civils sous le nom de badridine amadoune
le duo bottent leur amadoune aurait
dirigé une multitude de compagnies au
fil des ans en sécurité immobilier
construction transport
import-exporting santé
et derrière
l'entreprise Neptune serviceuse alors
qu'il n'est nulle part dans le registre
des entreprises qui n'est ni
administrateur ni actionnaire on peut
facilement tromper l'Autorité des
Marchés Publics
au niveau de une agence n'a pas donné
des bonnes informations concernant cette
situation payer un processus de
révocation de permis qui est
automatiquement enclenché mais est-ce
que vous êtes le vrai propriétaire de
Neptune
est-ce que c'est votre femme
propriétaire de Neptune Robert bottler a
dit en cours lui rendre des comptes une
ou deux fois par année la plupart du
temps à l'étranger
[Musique]
habite pourtant ici pas très loin des
bureaux de Neptune elle a refusé nous
parler
après coup on se pose des questions
comment se fait qu'on a donné des
contrats à l'entreprise comme ça est-ce
qu'on leur a réduite plus vigilant quoi
que ce soit mais il est peut-être plus
beau ce missionnaire il y avait son
accréditation il était conforme alors on
est obligé malgré tous les processus de
vérification neptune a pu décrocher des
centaines de contrats publics depuis 10
ans c'est très chacal puis surtout quand
la responsabilité de l'argent des
contribuable comme un jeune sécurité on
a un code d'éthique
c'est compliqué je comprends pas l'idée
d'accompagner le numéro
quel genre d'astuces on utilise où
j'apprécie un subterfu je trouve ça très
inquiétant que derrière une entreprise
qui a des millions de contrats publics
que cette personne là a une double
identité c'est une fronde nous avons
offert à Robert bottler et à badridine
amadoum de nous accorder une entrevue
une offre qui a été refusée on ne sait
toujours pas quel est sa réelle identité
on peut s'attendre à des développements
bientôt parce que l'Autorité des Marchés
Publics nous informer quelle enquête sur
Neptune à suivre donc
[Musique]